so I turn and I'm beating off in my own
corner think of this isn't that bad of a
gig I mean it beats going on the road
doing comedy so then it hits me
maybe I should be turned away from the
guy with the 14-inch penis
really good friend of mine in New York
I'm really excited to get on the show
he's absolute Alerus you guys will
absolutely love him give a warm round of
applause for mr. Aaron Berger it's weird
for me to be back in a strip club that's
how I started in showbiz I was a male
stripper for a while and I just did it
for a summer and then four years after
that but it's that up job and
it's different when we go then like if
women go like we go there's rules like a
bouncer comes over he's like sit down
drink your drink don't touch the girls
don't look Macaulay Culkin in the eye
and women go it's Vegas with penises
women in here very well behaved right
now you got him in a room with four
naked men they've never seen before and
a firefighter hat and some Bon Jovi
music and it's like that's not cheating
if I just rub it on my face I was it was
a weird time made me question my
sexuality made me question everything so
I'm training at the gym one day I'm
jacked under here you can't tell
shredded I I'm training and this
metrosexual guy walks up and he's like
hi how you doing I noticed you really
made some progress with your physique
over the past little while and I'm
thinking how long's this guy been
watching me for and at first I'm like
weird stalker but then I'm like
cool someone noticed he's like I
was wondering maybe one night if you're
free maybe you'd like to come over to my
place and we could work something out
you know maybe oppose a bit you know
maybe for an hour so and then when
you're done posing maybe we could just
watch each other finish and a Mike
finish what your hardwood floors with
the you getting at here
he's like I was wondering if you'd like
to come over in persons and masturbate
oh you you never masturbate in front of
a man before they're like no I blew a
dude when I was 12 but I never talked
about it and I never thought I'd see him
again
no and he's like look I know young
comfortable but I give you a hundred and
fifty dollars and if it makes you more
comfortable you can bring someone with I
gives the same amount of money to them
and I'm like more comfortable like this
is what me and my buddies do in our
spare time like hey old dude if you're
free next Friday you want to go jack off
in front of some weird dude no no you
got it wrong there's money involved now
there was this guy I used to strip with
named hot chocolate probably not his
real name but huge Jamaican dude and
against all racial stereotypes for a
black dude couldn't dance at all you
would just stare at you angry until you
gave up money any bit of what go on girl
get me some cash now and for the most
part Jamaican people and most people
from the islands very homophobic they
think it's wrong they think it's
blasphemy so I see hot chocolate outside
the gym and like hey mr. chocolate how
are you look I know you're not gay and
I'm not gay and you're not gay and I'm
not gay and we're not gay but this guy
approached me and he wants me to
masturbate in front of them and I know
you know K and I'm not gay we're not gay
but it's 150 dollars each and I want to
know if you want to come not come if you
want to go to the guy's house and he
said would if we'll come over here away
boy you'll just call me starting front I
tell me what may be big for us on
for a hundred and fifty dollar
not wrong that blasphemy God made them
people wrong here and I we're never
gonna beat me dick for some man for $150
and I never gonna beat me dick for some
man for 150 dollars in the future white
boy $200
I pick them up the next night my Nissan
Sentra put on some Bob Marley in the car
to make him feel comfortable and we're
driving and it's all I buffalo soldier
he's rolling up this big bat
like dreadlock rasta likes it what about
little man you want to hit someone at no
I'll have some thank you sir reach out
that's real sense a meal from jazz
greener not a chronic y'all white
people smoke this real emancipation weed
free our body free our mind like a
soldier how that make you feel and I'm a
kind of paranoid actually maybe
we should park the car like a block away
from the address underneath the trees
and no one sees my license plate and we
could put bushes in front of he's like
roll up from the post we cannot be done
because I get paid like professionals
and I'm like all right it's on get to
the house we ring the doorbell
metrosexual guy answers he's like
gentlemen how are you I'm what you guys
know each other he's like let's go
upstairs it's comfortable there you'll
like it I'm like yeah that's what I'm
here for is to like you're upstairs
living room not question my sexuality
based on a financial transaction we get
in this room he shuts the door he starts
taking his clothes off and he's all fat
and sweaty and pale and he's got stretch
marks all over his lower back looks like
he had a baby out of his ass hot
chocolate is this ripped nubian God with
this freak show in between his legs like
this is you it's 14 inches this is
Costco like you need it
a membership card to get near this thing
and it wasn't just that that would
hang there this was a black dick it had
rhythm like it would move to the beat of
the music so he'd be like shake think
miss Annabel shake that thing jump up
and he would catch the dick in between
his legs and it's not like white guy
dick when we do it like I've got a
surprise like there was a good six of
eight inches of rod still pokin at the
back and if you haven't seen a black
before you probably have but for
those of you that haven't your shits
dark is night but like the tip of it's
bright pink so it's kind of like a
Neapolitan car so these guys start
getting naked and I start getting naked
and I'm like look I'm very uncomfortable
like I was raised a privileged Jew I
should not be in this situation over a
hundred and fifty dollars and I don't
look Jewish I I look like I eat Jews and
mix them with protein powder but like
I'm like I don't want to your gig
up but I've never done this before what
do I do and he's like look just pose a
little bit and we all gonna masturbate
and we all come together mm-hmm
when I come I'm gonna take these poppers
you can if you want to now for those of
you that don't know poppers are amyl
nitrate drug used primarily in the gay
community they sniff it it slows
everything down and loosens them up for
the orgasm so they'll be like this is
the best day ever there's so much
varnish
and then Elton John plays and Angels
weep or something but this guy said
we're gonna come all together and I'm
thinking how do we organize that like is
a midget in a tux gonna run out like
come captain captain so these two guys
get hard right away and I'm thinking
don't look cuz that's gay so I turn and
I'm beaten off in my own corner think of
this isn't that bad of a gig I mean it
beats going on the road doing comedy so
then it hits me maybe I shouldn't
be turned away from the guy with the
14-inch penis you know just in case he
wants to take it to the next level or
something like reparation reparation and
reparation or black life splatter and so
I turned back and I can't get it up
because I'm jacking off in front of two
dudes and you know it's awkward so it's
kind of like this never happens I bloop
bloop and I'm just going at it I'm like
get hard get hard get hard I'm like
this is so gay and then I'm thinking
maybe it's not gay because there's money
involved so it's like you know like
performance art on the d-train and I'm
kind of and I'm like okay I think I get
common gay guys like when you come I
want it on me and I'm like that was not
part of the deal and I start coming and
it's weird cuz it feels good but then
it's wrong and he wants me to come on
him but I'm here he's there I'm locked
into my composition I can't like waddle
over there to come on him and I don't
want to go over there because if I do
then he can touch me now to me that's
gay but for some reason to you know
money
oh it's just a Jewish transaction so I'm
coming and I don't know what to do and I
don't want to disappoint the guy I don't
want hot chocolate the side
swiped me with his so I'm coming in
my hand and it's a good-sized load for
me and I don't know what to do so I line
up and I throw my count
and hot chocolate notices it looks all
surprised but kind of impressed like
I've made this new innovation in the
field of Circle Jerks or something so he
lines up and throws his time but when he
throws his he's got like way more like
he throws it it's like Casper the
Friendly Ghost just flew over my
shoulder and this is black come it's
athletic it's like running at the guy's
face it mines all jewy it's like with
traveling through the desert slowly and
both of our comes hit the guy's face and
hot chocolates is dripping down looks
like someone kicked over a salad bar at
Golden Corral and mine's just they're
all Joey like invest in gold at low
rates gay guys are covered in sweat and
comment groans like I don't out
of breath and exhausted and hot
chocolates like another day of the
office you know after this you ah we'll
grab our Anakin and I look over at a
dude and his head still down and he
looks like he's not breathing
nobody go hot chocolate hot chocolate
don't snap at a big black dude by the
way it's Brad what the is going on
with this guy y'all better machine up
before that role does some up
rogue some time not roped up me people
die on sorry what what was your
diagnosis their doctor chocolates died
and she I don't want to go to jail for
throwing come at a man
if this guy's dead if he's dead
or DNA is dripping down his face
CSI will solve this in two minutes just
the purple light just a hunch sauce
might be on the tow guys running across
along with dicks in their hands so hot
chuckles a who attained I'm a bull and
he runs out in the hallway and I'm like
you must be looking for a defibrillator
or something I don't know what he's
doing our first-aid kit and I start
getting dressed and gay dudes head still
down and times elapsing and I don't know
what to do and I don't want to touch him
cuz hot chocolates comes all over him
like I would touch my it smells like
pennies and bleach but I don't know if
he smells like curry or what so I
wrapped this tower in my hand and kind
of go over and shove his chest nothing
and had leaned in closer and I'm like
please don't let this guy died this is
such a horrible way and I shut them
again and I shut my eyes and then I hear
like is the guy inhaling I'm like oh my
god everything's gonna be okay and the
is him coming all over my leg and he's
so good and then hot chocolate comes in
he's out yo you're good we're good we're
good y'all good all right and then we
leave the next night I see hot chocolate
at work it's not a lot you can say to
someone after an incident like that it's
not really water-cooler talk is it like
a good throw last night I put my wallet
my cowboy costume inside the locker I go
outside I grab some Wendy's as I'm
waiting in line it hits me holy
there is no racism anymore there is no
anti-semitism there is no homophobia a
black man a Jew and a gay man all just
beat off and through comedy chowder
thank you so much